ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียม
คลิปนี้เป็นนักเรียนใช่สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะค่ะโคเรียมคัด
คลิปนี้เป็นคลิปที่เท่าไหร่คะของเราสองคน
คลิปนี้เป็นคลิปที่ 2 ของครูเรียมกับครู
เอ๋ค่ะเราก็วันนี้วันวันๆ
ท่านวันอาทิตย์ข่าววันหน้าวันนี้เป็นตัว
เองเจอต่างกล้าเอกเขียนก่อนนะคะว่าวัน
วันอาทิตย์ละคะใช้ค่ะหน้าวันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
วันที่เท่าขอให้น้า
วันที่พี่
23 ใช่มั้ย
ใช่ไหมลูก
24h ไม่ใช่ 23 อ๋อ
เป็นนี้ 24 ราคาคุยลบลบก่อนอาเป็นวันที่
ชายค่ะค่ะนะยี่สิบสี่เดือนอ่ะอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมหน้าเดือน
ตุลาคม
ปีพตเท่าไหร่นะคะปีพตต
ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะมีคศ 2000  21  2021
แต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้บ่าย 4 โมง 4
โมงแล้ว
ขอกูไม่ใช่ 3 วง RC โมง
[เพลง]
16:00 นใช่ไหมคะอ่ะอ่าใช่ค่ะกี่โมงเย็น
นะคะตอนนี้ 16:00 นอ่ะกูอ่ะลบนะคะมิอา
คุยหรอก -
เรียมขาวันนี้นะคะคุณเอ๋จะให้
กูเองว่าเอ๋มีจริงๆกูเองมีรูปนะคะมีรูป
โอ้มีรูป
มีลูกมากๆสิครูเอกในรูป 1
2  3  4  5  6  7  8
199 รูปนะคะมี 9 รูปแล้ว 9 รูปนั้นเป็น
รูปอะไรคะ
9 รูปเป็นรูปสัตว์ค่ะเป็นรูปสัตว์หน้า
แปลกจริงๆคู๋อยากได้ 12
12 รูป
r12 รูปแต่รูปหายไป
3 รูป
ทำไมคะครูเอ๋ทำไมรูปหายไปไม่รู้
ไม่แก่ไม่รู้รูปหายไปไหนร้านค้า
8 รูป 12 รูปใช่ไหมคะอ่าคุยลบตรงนี้ก่อน
ก็จะมีรูปทั้งหมดนะคะมี 122
เนื้อหาม 4
5  6
7 จะไปอะไรคะคุณเรียมแต่
9 กับอีก 11
ต้องมีรูปทั้งหมด
12 รูปนะคะ 12 รูปทำไมคะหนูเอ๋
คนเพราะอย่างนี้ค่ะครูเรียมอ่ะสมมุติครู
เอ๋นะคะอันนี้เป็นคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่
ค่ะแล้วก็คู๋
เวลาที่คุณแม่ท้อง
หมอ
คุณแม่ท้องเป็นคู๋อยู่ข้างใน
นะนาน
นานเท่าไหร่อ่ะ
ข้อ 9 เดือนหรอ 9 เดือน
9 เดือน
อ่ะแล้วคุณแม่ก็
นักๆๆๆ
เย้เป็นคุณแม่โอ๊ยคู่เตรียมคิดคุณแม่คุณ
แม่โอ๊ยออกคุณไหมเจ็บใช่ไหมเจ็บท้อคุณแม่
เจ็บนะคุณแม่ไม่ใช้อยู่ใช่คุณแม่โอ้ยโอ๊ย
เจ็บท้อง
เจ็บท้องเอ้ยเวลาคนไทยเจ็บท้องเนี่ยร้อง
โอ๊ย
กูให้ค่ะคุณเรียนรู้ไหมคนเอาบริการ.ร้อง
ยังไงคนยุโรปร้องยังไง
ไม่รู้ค่ะ
กูเอ๋รู้
ร้องยังไงคะปูโอ้โหได้ยินนักเรียนบอก
ตั้งเวลาเวลาโดนตีแล้วเจ็บอ่ะคนไทยโอ๊ยคน
อเมริกาคนยุโรป
ๆ
ถ้าโดนตีแล้วคนไทยคิด Again
เพลงฝรั่งคนต่างชาติร้อง
คนญี่ปุ่นคนญี่ปุ่นญี่ปุ่นญี่ปุ่นญี่ปุ่น
หรอ 2 ว่าอะไรคะญี่ปุ่นญี่ปุ่นอดิศร์
ประเทศญี่ปุ่นธงธงญี่ปุ่นสีแดง
อะนี้สีแดงใช่มะคนญี่ปุ่น
อ่ะอะคนญี่ปุ่นเนาะคนญี่ปุ่นไม่ร้องอุ้ย
ไม่ร้องเอาเสือ
ร้องว่าอะไรคะ
เวลาโดนตี้ Kitty
เฮ้ย
อิไตอิไตอิไตอิไตอิไตอิไตๆ
เจ็บๆเจ็บ
เจ็บน้าคนไทยก็โอ๊ยเจ็บนะฮะๆนี่ค่ะอะทิ
นี้อะเขต - นี้ก่อนนะคะอ่าคุณแม่น่ะว่า
เจ็บท้องคุณแม่คุณแม่คุณแม่คุย
คุณแม่
เจ็บท้องแล้วก็คลอด
บุกเอกอะ
แล้วสวัสดีคุณแม่
อ๋อ
ก็กูออกมาแล้วพระเอกก็สวัสดีจะมีค่าาไว้
ไม่ได้
ไม่ได้กูแอบพูดไม่ได้อ๋อคู๋ยังไม่ได้ฟัง
ภาษาไทย
[เพลง]
เรียกร้อง
เอกก็โอ้ยๆ
เพราะว่ากูเอ๋ยังไม่ได้พูดภาษาไทยนะคะ
นะคะ
ที่นี้นะคะลบเกี่ยวอะไรกับรูปสิบเกี่ยว
ค่ะเพราะว่าพอกูเอ๋คุณแม่คลอดฉะนั้นคุณ
เนี่ยโอ้ยคลอดกูเองเห้ย
ครูเอ๋แนะเกิดชนัฐเกิด
เกิด
วันที่สีแดงไม่เอากูเองไม่ชอบสีแดงรึป่าว
สิน
วันที่ 16
16 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีสภาคม
AE
ปี 1968
1968 พระรูปนี้ตรวจวันที่ 16 พฤษภาคม
2551  968 ถ้าปีไทยปีไทยนะ
2,000
[เพลง]
ปุ๊ป
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เฮ้ย 13 ปี
ว้าว
มาคะครูเอ๋อายุ
53 ปี
เอไม่มีพร๊อปฟิตเนตนะคะอายุ 53 ปีคู่
เลี้ยงม.มขาไม่พูดก็ได้นะคะแต่ถ้านัก
เรียนคือครูเอ๋โอเคนะเพราะว่าสอนภาษาไทย
นานๆออกไม่มีติดหนาอ่ะ
ผู้เรียนก็โอเคโอเคนะโอเคผู้เตรียมอายุ 25
ปีใช่ไหมคะอย่าให้
กูเรียมคูเรียมเกิดนะคะคนอื่นลบลบไปนี้
ให้ก่อนมา
คู่เตรียมเกิดกูอ่ะเขียนให้ก็ได้ค่ะอัน
นี้ครูเหลี่ยม
คู่เรียมนะคะอุ้ยสวยๆ
บุเรียมเกิดวันที่เท่าไหร่คะเกิดวันที่ 6
วันที่ 6 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคมเดือน
สิงหาคม
นี้ปีอะไรคะปี
1992 นะคะปีไทยอีไทย
R2  535
ไม่คุยกำลังคิดตื้นๆอายุไม่ได้คิดอายุคิด
1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10  11  12
คือนักเรียนคะอ่านักเรียนบอกก็ทำไมคนไทย
พูดอายุไม่ I หรอ
คนไทยโอเค
พูดอายุ
53 อายุไม่เป็นไรปีเกิดเท่าไหร่นะ 29 ปี
ค่ะ
และแล้วเป้นะคะ
คนไทยพูดอายุโอเคแต่บางคนไม่พูดอายุเวลา
ถามเกิดปีอะไร
ดีอะไรใช่มะครูเรียมเกิดปีอะไรนะคะ
เรียมเกิดปีวอก
9926 เป็นการ์ตูน
อ่ะเลี้ยงเกิดปีอะไรนะ
ครูเอกเกิด
1968 นะคะ R  R ที่นี้น่ะพ่อถามปีเป็น
นัมเบอร์บางคนไม่โอเคเราก็จะถามเป็นปี
สับ
พวกคือมีสัตว์ล่ะคะปีนักษัตร
รักสัตว์นักษัตรมีทั้งหมด
22 ปีนะคะ
12 ปีงั้นคู๋จะลบปีอันนี้ออกแบบนักเรียน
จำ
เราลบออก
ลบๆออกอ่ะอ่ะอ่ะลบ
มี 12
12  12 นักษัตรใช่ไหมคะ 12 นักษัตรค่ะ
แบบคู่เอ๋มีรูปเนี่ย 9 นะเนี่ยรูปที่ไม่
มีครูเอกจะวาดนะ
ได้ปีที่ 1 เนี่ยอ่าปีหนูอาปีหนูทีหนูจะ
วัดเหมือนไหมกูเตรียม
อ่ะโอเค
เหมือนไหม
นี่ / ฉันอ่านขา
หนูโอเคไหมอ่ะถ้าไม่มีหู
ร้อง
หนูราะ
ปีหนูนะคะหนู
อ่ะ
โอเคมั้ยโอเคโอเคค่ะ
กูตัว
กูจะเหมือนหมาหาแฟนไหมเนี่ย
พี่ไม่อยากช่วยอยากช่วยว่าจังเลยน้อง
เรียนช่วยหน่อย
เป็นอย่างนี้ไหมอ่ะ
ในเว็บช่วยคู๋ว่าไม่เก่ง
หนูแบบนี้ไหนคะ
[เพลง]
ใช่ๆอ่าดูซิและเตรียมก่อนอ่ะแม่
โอเค
ปีที่ 1 ที่ 1 เป็นหนูนาหนู
ใช่
ปีที่ 2 ไม่ต้องวาด
ครูเองมีลูกมีรูปปีที่ 2 อันนี้ปีที่ 2
ปีที่ 2 เป็นอะไรคะตีวัวมีมัวนะครับเป็น
วัวนะคะกูแล้วกินวัวไหม
กินได้ค่ะแตกไม่ชอบกินชอบกินอาปีที่ 2
นักเรียนปีวัวอ่ะ
ปีที่ 1 ปีหนูปีที่ 2 เนี่ยปีวัวเรา
ปีที่แม่น้ำ
ที่ 3 ปีอะไรคะปีที่ 3 ปีอันนี้เลยค่ะคุณ
เลี่ยมปีอะไรเค้าปีเสือปีซื้ออาหารเสือ
เสือเบงกอลด้วยนะเนี่ย
ปีเสือนะคะอา
ปีแล้วต้องปีที่ 4 ปีที่ 4 นะคะก็คือปี
นี้เลยค่ะครูเรียมมีอะไรคะปีกระต่ายปี
กระดูกต้องเห็นปากใช่มั้ยปีกระต่ายปี
กระต่ายภาษาใต้กินอะไรอยู่คะน้าบ่ายกิน
แครอท
กระต่ายโข
ยาวเนอะยาว
ยาวคู่เตรียมหูยาวไหมไม่ๆ
โอ้โหท่าน
เล็กๆฮ่าๆๆฮ่าถ้าเป็นกระต่ายจะหูยาวในหู
ยาวอ่ะงั้นปีที่ 4 น้องปีกระต่ายนะคะๆค่ะ
ต่อไปปีที่ 5
ปีที่ 5 กูเองไม่มีคนลืมบ้านได้ไหมได้ค่ะ
ปีงูงู
ปิ้งโอ้ว
ยังไง
เลี้ยงอะไรวันนี้ไงวันนี้ไงกูก็เป็นอย่าง
นี้ไงอ๋อค่ะญานาคนะ
โอเคโอเคเอาใหม่เอาใหม่ลบลบลบ
ๆๆ
[เพลง]
เอา
งูต่างงอนแล้วมีตังค์มีหัวมีข้างบน
ข้างบนด้วย
มีข้อมูลได้เหรอคะพญานาค
นะคะเดี๋ยวนะคะหนูใหญ่ขอเป็นใหญ่เอองูอัน
นี้ติดชนิดก่อนนะคะปีที่ 4 แล้วใช่ไหมคะ
อันนี้ปีที่ 5 ใช่ไหมปีที่ 5 กู any ปี
ที่ 6 คืองูเล็กแต่กูเอกได้งูใหญ่ๆ
งูตายเหอะก็โคเรียมว่าเด็กเล็กอันนี้เล็ก
ใช่ไหมคะมีหัวมีหัวเพิ่มเพิ่มหัว
หัวแบบนี้นะคะก็ไม่อาจเพิ่ม
อ๋ออ๋อโอเคแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
หัวเป็นพญานาคอ่ะลูกอ่ะฮะโอเคครูเอ๋
ได้ไหม
โอเคๆนิดหน่อยหน่อย
งูใหญ่หนูใหญ่ๆเดี๋ยวกูอีกว่าให้ดูด้วย
ว่าให้ดูนะ
อ้าปีกหนาปีที่แล้วกันนะปีที่ 2 ติดปีที่
1 หนูปีที่ 2 วัวใช่ไหมคะใครเขาบัวงวัว
กลัวที่ร้อง
มองปีที่ 3 เสือเสือ
มาเอาปีที่ 4 กระต่าย
นะคะกินกระตาย
[เพลง]
ปีที่ 5 การ pitch ที่ 5 นี่เลยงูแบบนี้
ยังไงคะ
หมู่ที่มีหัวแบบนี้
ฉันโห
ดีกูใหญ่งูใหญ่อะไรอ่ะงูใหญ่บางทีเรียก
พญานาค
พญานาคระบุเตรียมไม่รู้
เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋อะให้นักเรียนดูเนาะ
กูเองจะมีไหม
ไม่ไหวอ่ะกูเองยังไม่ได้เปิดไว้เดี๋ยวครู
เปิด
เปิดเปิด
รูปขยะหน้ากากค่ะให้ค่ะ
รีบดู
นี่โอเคเดี๋ยวนะคะ a คอร์ด A เปิดแล้ว
อันนี้ไม่เอาได้ไหม
งั้นติดอันนี้อยู่จะตอบเรื่อง
ขอโทษค่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะอ่า
โอเค
นี่ค่าปีที่ 5
โอ้ยพญานาคพี่ค่ะญานาค
นิดถือว่างูใหญ่หายพูดงูใหญ่แต่พูดพญานาค
โอเค
น่าใข้นั้นเป็นปีที่ 5 แล้วปีต่อไปล่ะคะ
กี่ที่ 6 ปีที่ 6  5 ปีที่หกใช่ไหมคะ
ปีที่ 6 เป็น
งูเล็ก
ของูเล็กงูเล็กๆอ่า
โอเค or  Less  on ตัวเล็กๆงูเล็ก
r&d จิ๊บ 7 ปีทิศ 7 เป็นปีนักษัตรอะไรคะ
อีกที่เจ็ดเป็นปีหน้าจะอ้ามีนี่คุยว่าไม่
เป็นเหมือนกัน
ขออะไรคุณเรียมม้าม้าม้าร้องยังไง
ใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็จะดีได้ยินเสียงเท้าเท้าม้าตลกๆๆๆๆ
ๆ
ผู้เรียนเห็น Mark มั้ย
ใช่เหรอคะคู๋
คนว่าแล้วคอมพิวเตอร์มันมันขยับอ่าอ๋อม้า
อ่าโอเคนะอ้าอย่างนี้เนาะ
แต่ก็มีอีกนี้
[เพลง]
โอเคไหมเตรียมคิดว่าเหมือนยูนิคอร์น
ยูนิคอร์นมาเหมือนกันโอเคเขาเป็นมาร์คมี
เขา
ม้าม้าๆนะคะ
ปิดที่ 8 ปีที่ 8 ปีนักษัตรอะไรคะปีที่ 8
เป็นปีนักษัตรและๆแอนด์
พีแทะปีแพะฮ่าๆ
ๆแพะร้องยังไงนะคะคือเองร้องแพ้
แพ้
แซะๆ
นั่งดื่มจะบอกกูเองว่าไม่เหมือน
แต่
มันมีอีก 1 ตัวคล้ายๆแพะได้ไหม
ให้อ้ายแพ้กูเองมีลูก
ครูนะคะโพเรียมรอถ้า
มีอะไรคะได้ขายแพ้นี่นิวซีแลนด์
นิวซีแลนด์มีที่มีขนฟูใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะอ๋อ
ใช่เลยนี่
อันนี้เป็นอะไรคะ
แกะแกะอันนี้เป็นอะไรค่ะ
แพะ
แพะแกะแกะแป๊ะ
ปวดหัว
แต่ว่าปีที่ 8 เป็นปีนักษัตร
มีแพะคน
ก็แคะ
คนถ่ายนะก็บอกคนไทยคนไทยเป็นแพะนะครับปี
ที่ 8
B ที่ 9 ไม่มีโรค
เป็นปีอะไรคะเป็นปีเดี๋ยวกูเองไว้ให้ก่อน
นะปีที่ 9 เปลี่ยนอันนี้
[เพลง]
นักเรียนคิดว่าเป็นปีอะไรคะ
5 เหมือนไหมน้อ
ไม่เหมือนใช่ไหมอ๋อ
เรียนรู้ค่ะเลี้ยงรู้แล้วนักเรียนรู้มั้ย
นักเรียนรู้ไหมคะอ่ะ
อ่ะ
เฮ้อตีอะไรปีอะไร
กล้วยมีรูปเล็กๆ
เป็นสัตว์ที่กินกล้วยใช่ไหมคะกินกล้วยกิน
กล้วย
นี่ค่าค่ะครูเรียนมีเล็กๆ
อ๋อ
อะไรคะ
ลิงลิงนะฮะปีที่ 9
ปีที่ 9 เป็นลิงลิง
ได้ค่ะ
ต่อไปปีที่ 10 เป็นตัวนี้ค่ะคุณเรียมอะไร
นิสิตฮ้อ
ไก่ตีไก่ค่ะไก่กุ๊กไก่อ่านง่ายๆ
ไก่ไก่ร้องยังไงคะอ่ะกไก่ไก่ตัวผู้
หรือตัวเมียคะโพเรี่ยมได้ก็ผู้
ตัวนี้ไก่ตัวผู้ไก่ตัวผู้กับ
บ้านคุณมีแล้วไก่ตัวเมียล่ะคะ
แล้วก็คะลูกลูกไก่
ลูกไก่
เล็กๆจะร้อง
ใช่ๆแล้วจุ๊บๆ
หน่อยจุ๊บๆๆๆ
ค่ะอันนี้ไก่นะฮะปีที่สิบ
ปีที่ 11 อีกที่ 11 คือปีอะไรคะนี่ค่ะ 11
มีดีอะไรคะคุณเลียมส์ลูกสุนัข
สุนัขมาเลี้ยงพูดว่าปีหมาใช่ปีหมาทำไมคุย
ว่าเหมือนหมูเลยอ่ะ
หมาที่เห่ากุ้งห้องช้างห้องซ้ายปี 41
เป็นปีหมามหาปีมา
แล้วปีสุดท้ายปีสุดท้ายอาร์คูลเลียมดูของ
นักเรียนบอกทุกรูปเหมือนกันหมด
อ๋อ
มีอะไรคะ
มีหมูเหม่ง
แฮปปี้หมูนะคะที่ร้องกู๊ดๆ
ใช่ค่ะพูดๆ
ทรายกูลโป้ขา
โคเรียมเราทวน 12 ปีอีกหนึ่งครั้งนะคะปี
ที่ใหญ่นะครับปีที่ 1 ปีอะไรนะพี่เอ๋ Stop
screen  Goo
ปีกที่ 1 เป็นปี้ปีหนู
หน้าเหมือน
ปีที่ 2 เป็นปีอะไรคะหารูป
ปีวัวค่ะปีที่ 2 ของปีมูลวัววัว
ร้องยังไงนะ
มอหม่อ
อะโคเรียนถามตัวเองปีที่ 3 ปีนักษัตรอะไร
คะปีที่ 3 เป็นปีนักษัตรสื่อเสือหาว้าว
cc เสียเสือร้องยังไงคุณเรียนรู้ไหม
ไม่รู้ค่ะเสือร้องยังไงคะโห
โคลโห
แล้วพี่ที่ 4 ล่ะคะอีที่ 4
ปีที่ 4 ปิ๊มีอะไรคู่เตรียมมีกระต่ายหาก
เป็นปีกระต่ายกระต่ายร้องยังไงคู่เลี่ยม
[เพลง]
ไม่เคยได้ยินเสียงกระต่าย
คูเอกก็ไม่เคยได้ยิน
แล้วก็กระต่ายร้องยังไงคะไม่รู้
นักเรียนได้ยินไหมกระต่ายร้องยังไง
สองร้อยไม่น้องกระต่ายไม่
พี่น้องนะเออ
แล้วปีที่ 5 ล่ะคะไปที่ 5 งูใหญ่พญานาค
ของหรือใหญ่ใช่มั้ยพญานาคชายค่ะปีที่ 6
ปีที่ 6 งูเล็กกูเล็กอา
[เพลง]
ตีที่ที่ 7
มีอะไรคะปีม้าปีม้า
ปีทิพย์ 8 ปีที่ 8 ปีอะไรคะดีที่ 8 ปีแพะ
ค่ะจริงที่ 9
ปีลิง
สีลิงค์
บิชิติดค่า
จีไก่ปีกไก่ปีที่
11 ค่ะ
A หมาตีหมาอุ้ยดีที่ 12 ปีหมูปีหมูทีนี้
เรามี
12 ปีใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะเก็บสองปี 12 ปีเวลา
คนไทยถามคนไทยถาม
เกิดปีอะไร
ไม่ต้องพูด
2511 ไม่ต้องพูดโอเคเหมือนถ้าเรียมถาม
ครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋เตรียมถามเอ๋ล่ะเกิดปีอะไรคะ
คู่เอกเกิดปีที่ 9 ปีลิงค่ะ
ปิ้ง
โคเรียมนะคะเกิดปีอะไร
มีคู่เรียงก็เกิดปีที่ 9 รุ่น Li
โคเรียมกับคู๋ปีลิงลิง
เหมือนกันใช้ค่ะเหมือนกันเลย
แล้วเราไม่รู้นักเรียนเกิดปีอะไรนะคะนาน
นักเรียนเกิดบิ๊กหนู
ปีวัว
ไอ้ตัวนี้ก็ได้เนาะปีวัวปีนะคะปีเสือปี
วัว
ปี
เสือ
ปีปีกระต่าย
กระต่าย
ตีงูใหญ่ๆ
บีมีอะไรดูเล็กงูเล็กถ้ามีอะไรคะปีม้าปี
ม้าปีอะไรคะอีแทะ
ปีแพะปีลิง
ผู้หญิงไทย 2 คนปีลิงนะคะหาแล้วก็ปีอะไร
คะตีไก่แล้วก็ปีอะไรคะปีหมาแล้วสุด 12 ปี
ปีหมูอันที่ 12 ปีหมูคู่เรียม
นักเรียนเกิดปีอะไร
ปีอะไรอ่าใช่ค่ะนักเรียนเกิดปีอะไรคะมี
อะไร
พิมพ์คอมเม้นไว้ด้านล่างนะคะใช่มั้ยนัก
เรียนเกิดปีอะไรคู่เรียนอยากรู้ใช่ไหมใช่
ค่ะผู้เรียนก็อยากรู้ลูกเอกก็อยากรู้อ่ะ a
f  b ลิงค์
เพียงผู้ทีมก็ปีนยิง
แกสองคนอายุไม่เท่ากันนะอ่าอันนี้ลิงพี่
ลิงเนาะน้อง
เอ๋ไม่รู้วันนี้รู้ครูเรียมปีลิงนะคะอ่า
เงินค่ะเราสองคนอยากรู้นักเรียนที่ฟังเรา
รู้ไหมนักเรียนปีนักษัตรอะไรนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะขอ
เราจะรู้ได้ยังไงคะต้องไปดูที่ไหนคะต้อง
มีหาที่ไหนคะถ้านักเรียนไม่รู้นักเรียน
เขียนคอมเม้น
ชั้นเกิด
นะคะอ่านักเรียนคอมเมนต์ฉันเกิด
นักเรียนคอมเมนต์ฉันเกิด
[เพลง]
1990 บาทสมมติไมเคิลบอกๆไม่ 1990
ปีเตอร์
นักเรียนคอมเมนต์ปีเกิด
คอมเม้นไว้ด้านล่างนะคะถ้าเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋
ครูเรียมบอกปีอะไร
ใช่ค่ะแต่คลิปนี้เนี่ยเลยเวลาแล้วครู
เรียง
หมดเวลาแล้วหมดแล้วไก่มั้ยครับจะตา
ไก่อิ่มแล้วก็นอนแล้วใช่ไหมค่ะเที่ยงยัง
สนุกอยู่เลยค่ะสนุกใช่มั้ยไม่เป็นไร
เดี๋ยวเราคลิป 3 ได้บ่จะขอเดี๋ยวรอดูใน
คลิปต่อไปนะคะถ้าเลยค่ะตอนนี้นะหมดเวลา
ของคลิปที่ 2 แล้วครูเอ๋ครูเรียมไปก่อนนะ
คะถ้านะคะนอยากฟังครูเอ๋กับครูเรียมสอน
ภาษาไทยก็กดไลค์กดอะไรคะกด Subscribe กด
แพ้แล้วก็คอมเม้นข้างล่างให้เราสองคนนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะต้องขอขอบคุณนักเรียนนะคะที่เข้ามา
ดู
คุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนมา
[เพลง]